in four months and 10 days four months
and 10 days
so that a full legal
legally valid tax wouldn't for that
goal would need to be ready by the end
of october at the latest
in order to leave sufficient time to the
council
and to the european parliament on our
side to
approve we therefore
still have two months left to find
agreement on all the issues
under discussion to consolidate the
texts
and to finalize all the technical
annexes which are far from negligible
and then to have our legal experts
verify and validate the text in all the
language versions this is a
long and complex task any
delay beyond the end of october would
entail
a risk serious risk as to the
successful outcome of this process in
this context
those who were hoping for negotiations
to move swiftly forward this week will
have been disappointed
and unfortunately i too uh um
frankly disappointed and concerned and
surprised as well i must say
because the british prime minister boris
johnson told us
in june that he wished to speed up the
negotiating process
during the summer but this week once
again
as in the july round
the british negotiators have not shown
any
real willingness to move forward on
issues of fundamental importance for the
european union and this despite
the flexibility which we have shown
over recent months in terms of
taking on board and working with
the three red lines which boris johnson
himself set out
in june on the namely on the role of the
european court of justice uk legislative
autonomy
and on fisheries we still haven't seen
from uh our british partners
a any willingness to take on board
the eu's priorities ladies and gentlemen
um there is nothing
surprising whatsoever about the eu's
priorities because they have not
changed since 2017.
if we invite you to have a look again at
the uh
conclusions of the european council
resolutions of the european parliament
we have said repeatedly since 2017
what are our priorities for a balanced
and fair agreement with the
united kingdom and we continue with
great patience and
goodwill to repeat these
we must have a fair any trade agreement
must
go hand in hand with fair uh
standards mutually agreed standards a
level of playing field
we then need secondly we need to have a
long-term perspective
for european fishermen and thirdly there
won't be
any cherry-picking we won't have a la
carte
access to the internal market
because because of brexit britain
britain were to refuses to accept the
rules and obligations
of the internal marketplace it means
brexit these are not
dogmatic or technocratic
or ideological uh approaches by the
european union there's nothing tactical
about this we have to put this
point across clearly underscoring
these priorities which we have repeated
over the last four years we have
human social economic environmental
needs to defend which remain of
fundamental importance for us in which
we have to defend let me take a very
tangible example that of road
freight transport and this is something
which in the united
kingdom we've seen this in recent days
and the british press
has given rise to a lot of
emotion four
years after the brexit referendum vote
what is happening are the clear and
direct consequences
of the brexit vote nobody should be
surprised at that in britain
road transport is a key sector for
our economies it represents millions of
jobs in europe
and it is a sector which also has
a direct impact on logistical costs for
our
businesses prices paid by consumers
has a direct impact on pollution and
climate and indeed on
road safety as well